he said it was an exceptional measure a
response to economic and political
crises
[Music]
on july 25 president kaiser sacked prime
minister hisham mashishi froze
parliament and seize judicial power he
insists it was not a coup but others
call it a threat to one of the region's
few democracies
these decisions have no basis in the
constitution nor in the law this is a
coup against the constitution against
the 2011 revolution and against
liberties
in one month the president has dismissed
and replaced ministers and promised to
crack down on corruption but several mps
have been arrested with court cases
being fast-tracked al jazeera's bureau
was shut down without an explanation and
two new york times reporters were
detained briefly kaisai though is
promising freedom of expression
despite the crisis that tunisia is
living it still operates with freedom of
expression and with human rights built
on the constitution and if faced with
some difficulties in some areas or with
some administrations then these aren't
intentional obstacles
while syed has been trying to reassure
tunisia's unions and human rights groups
concerns still remain there is
an administrative decision called s-17
by the tunisian state it was used before
for for so many years especially with
regards to terrorists uh preventing
suspects
from of terrorism from leaving the
country
this is being expanded to other
categories including mps
former
government members
some
businessman
so how much time this is going to take
is an essential issue
since the freezing of parliament there's
little appetite to protest president
sayed's decision appears to be popular
but tunisians say they're fed up with
high unemployment and rising poverty
both made worse by the pandemic and they
blame the main political parties
including the largest sanada for this
since the crackdown the party has
softened its rhetoric and acknowledged
past mistakes
it's been difficult for everyone let's
be honest even akhtar is to blame for
that it should have been stronger stayed
away from political and fighting and
focused instead on economic achievements
to meet the demands of tunisian society
the arab spring changed tunisia
dramatically and put the country on a
path away from dictatorship and towards
democracy but there's still a sense of
uncertainty as tunisians wait to see
what kaiseid's long-term plans for the
country prove to be
al jazeera